[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihnen allen schönen guten
Abend Handball und Tennis später mit
ihrem sporting und was tolles Olympia
guten Abend was fast schon als
ausgemacht galt das wurde heute
offiziell hier sind unsere Themen
erwarteter Rückzug Christine Lamprecht
gibt ihr Amt als Verteidigungsministerin
auf Nachfolge ungewiss
Streit über Wahlrechtsreform die Union
kritisiert die ampelpläne scharf und
spricht von organisierter Wahlfälschung
und Tod einer Leinwand Diva die
italienische Schauspielerin Gina
Lollobrigida stirbt im Alter von 95
Jahren
[Musik]
es ist das Ende persönlicher Pannen in
Kommunikation und Amtsführung
Verteidigungsministerin Lamprecht bat
heute Vormittag offiziell um Entlassung
eigene Fehler räumt sie in ihrer kurzen
Erklärung nicht ein ein Rückzug nach
drei Tagen brodelnder Gerüchteküche und
die brodelt auch vorerst weiter denn die
Nachfolgefrage bleibt unbeantwortet der
Kanzler zahlt Lamprecht Respekt und muss
jetzt eine Entscheidung treffen die
sitzt in istans
der Kanzler zu Besuch bei einer
Rüstungsfirma in Ulm wer Christine
Lamprecht nachfolgen soll will er heute
noch nicht sagen ich habe eine klare
Vorstellung und das wird sehr schnell
für alle bekannt werden wie das
weitergehen soll Lambrecht bei ihrem
letzten öffentlichen Auftritt am Freitag
heute ist sie bereits nicht mehr im
Ministerium das was anfällt regelt sie
von zu Hause am Morgen ihre Rücktritt
schreiben Selbstkritik Fehlanzeige die
Monate lange ideale Fokussierung auf
meine Person lässt eine sachliche
Berichterstattung und Diskussion über
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
Bundeswehr und sicherheitspolitische
Weichenstellungen im Interesse der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Deutschlands kaum
zu es war eine Aufgabe die Lambrecht nie
wirklich wollte es fehlte ihr der Zugang
zur Bundeswehr der Draht zur Truppe 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen begann
sie eher zögerlich auszugeben fehlende
Munition bestellte sie zu spät eine
große Strukturreform von Ministerium und
Beschaffungswesen wollte sie nicht
angehen hinzu kamen Pannen ein Flug im
Bundeswehr Heli mit dem Sohn zuletzt
irritiert sie mit einem silvester-video
sie hat so viel finanzielle
Möglichkeiten bekommen wie keine
Ministerin kein Minister vorher und sie
hat sie nicht genutzt das heißt die
Zeitenwende hat in der Bundeswehr bisher
nicht stattgefunden das ist ihre
Verantwortung große Aufgaben warten auf
den oder die neue eine Umstellung der
Truppe auf Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung eine bessere
Ausrüstung einer kaputt gesparten
Bundeswehr
die Lage in der Bundeswehr ist prekär
das war sie vor Kriegsbeginn Stichwort
Russland Ukraine und sie ist es jetzt
erst recht warum die Unmengen an
ausrüstungsabgaben zurecht an die
Ukraine aber es kommt eben zu wenig
Gerät nach die Zeit drängt es stehen
große Entscheidungen an auf den
US-Stützpunkt Rammstein treffen sich am
Freitag die westlichen Verbündeten unter
anderem geht es um die Frage von
kampfpanzerlieferungen an die Ukraine
heute ist offen wer Deutschland dort
vertreten wird
ja gibt einiges zu besprechen das machen
wir mit Theo call in Berlin guten Abend
Theo wie ist dieser Rückzug zu bewerten
als ein Eingeständnis des Scheiterns und
einer offensichtlich tiefen Frustration
bei der Ministerin über ihre mediale
Wahrnehmung dass sie sich jetzt hinter
einer dürren schriftlichen Erklärung
versteckt und geht wieder weitere
Öffentlichkeit vermeidet das ist ja wie
ein Spiegelbild dieser Geschichte und
dazu passt natürlich auch dass sie als
zurücktrittsgrund den monatelangen Fokus
der Medien auf ihre Person nennt also
schuld sind die Medien von einem
Eingeständnis eigener Fehler kein Wort
für den Bundeskanzler scheint ja alles
klar das haben wir eben gehört warum
entscheidet er nicht wenn alles klar ist
naja er spricht ja nur von einer klaren
Vorstellung die er hat aber
offensichtlich hat er auch ein klares
Problem bei der Stellenbesetzung denn
sonst hätte er diese seit Tagen
andauernde politische nebelwanderung nie
zulassen dürfen und das Olaf Scholz noch
immer keinen Namen präsentiert das heißt
ja auch im politischen Klartext das
Problem der Stellenbesetzung ist größer
als der Kanzler nach außen vermitteln
will was auch nicht wirklich verwundert
denn das Amt ist zwar bedeutend aber vor
allem ein bewährter Karriere Killer wer
immer jetzt auf Lambrecht folgt der
beginnt mit Kaltstart ohne Schonfrist
und auf einem Schleudersitz und das zu
hören wir jetzt hier in Berlin schon am
Donnerstag denn dann hat Scholz einen
Termin beim Bundespräsidenten danke für
die Einschätzung nach Berlin Theo Paul
russland hat gemeinsam mit Belarus einen
Manöver der Luftstreitkräfte begonnen
auf Bela russischem Boden und damit
wächst die Sorge wieder das Präsident
Putin des Land für Angriffe gegen die
Ukraine einspannen könnte zwei Wochen
lang sollen die Übungen andauern in der
ukrainischen Stadt niebro geht die Suche
nach Vermissten nach dem russischen
Raketenangriff auf ein Hochhaus weiter
die Zahl der Todesopfer hat sich auf
mindestens 40 erhöht viele Menschen
werden noch vermisst
bundesaußenministerin baerbock will sich
dafür einsetzen ein internationales
Sondertribunal zu schaffen das den
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
aufarbeiten soll dies sei notwendig um
die russische Führung zur Rechenschaft
zu ziehen vor dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof in Den Haag können
regulär nur Fälle von Mitgliedern des
Gerichtshofes verhandelt werden Russland
und die Ukraine gehören nicht dazu
die Ampelkoalition hat sich auf eine
Wahlrechtsreform geeinigt und packt
damit ein ziemlich heißes Eisen an und
wir können uns dieses Problem mal
gemeinsam anschauen das Parlament wird
ja immer größer 2002 da waren es noch
63 Abgeordnete und dann gab es von Wahl
zur Wahl immer mehr Ausgleichsmandate
und zuletzt da wuchs der Bundestag auf
76 Sitze an zu groß und zu teuer und
jetzt soll die Reform das Parlament
wieder auf die gesetzlich eigentlich
vorgesehene Größe von 598 sitzen
begrenzen Patricia Wiedemeier mit den
Reaktionen
der heutige Bundestag der ist im
internationalen Vergleich eines der
größten Parlamente in einem erneuten
Anlauf will die Ampel nun die Zahl der
Abgeordneten verkleinern Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate abschaffen das
Wahlrecht verändern mit unserem
Vorschlag wird der Bundestag um etwa 20
Prozent kleiner das bedeutet aber dass
alle Fraktionen um 20% kleiner werden
müssen und nicht alle Fraktionen außer
der Union insgesamt soll es künftig 299
Wahlkreise geben für die Sitzverteilung
im Bundestag ist künftig nur die
Zweitstimme verantwortlich die Stimme
für die Stärke der Partei sie soll dann
Hauptstimme heißen wir führen eine
doppelte Legitimation an die Wählerinnen
und Wähler entscheiden über die
Hauptstimme welche Partei überhaupt
Sitze bekommt man muss über fünf Prozent
der Stimmen erhalten oder drei
grundmandate erreichen im Bundesgebiet
doch die Stimmen für die Partei alleine
reichen nicht mehr zusätzlich müssen die
Kandidaten auch direkt gewählt sein
gewählt ist man eben mit einer Deckung
durch die Hauptstimme also ausreichende
Stimmen für die Partei und eben
ausreichenden Stimmen im Wahlkreis das
ist die neue Definition von derjenige
ist gewählt durch diese neue Regelung
kann es im Einzelfall passieren dass
direkt gewählte Kandidaten wenn es nicht
genügend Mandate für die Partei gibt
nicht ins Parlament einziehen für linke
und CSU nicht akzeptabel die Ampel
verweigert direkt gewählten Abgeordneten
den Einzug ins Parlament das ist
ungeheuerlich und das können wir sonst
eigentlich nur von Türken starten trotz
aller Kritik noch vor Ostern will die
Ampel ihre Form verabschieden Gespräche
mit der Union wurden für diese Woche
angeboten aber eine wirklich breite
Mehrheit für die Wahlrechtsreform ist
derzeit nicht in Sicht
nach der Räumung von lützerath geht der
Energiekonzern RWE davon aus dass die
tagebaubagger den Ort im Frühjahr
erreichen und die darunterliegende
Braunkohle dann Abbaggern können die
letzten beiden Aktivisten haben den
unterirdischen Tunnel unter der Siedlung
freiwillig verlassen tagelang hatten sie
sich dort verschanzt anders so gab es
auch Proteste am Morgen hatten sich
Demonstranten darunter zwei im Rollstuhl
von einer Autobahnbrücke in der Nähe von
lützerath abgesagt
die zwei Terrorverdächtigen von
Castrop-Rauxel hatten für den
Silvesterabend einen Anschlag geplant so
das Ergebnis eines sonderberichts des
Justizministeriums in NRW am Donnerstag
wurde die Wohnung der beiden Iraner dann
nochmals durchsucht und dabei haben
Ermittler weitere Beweismittel
sichergestellt mehr von dort Färber
polizeilicher Großeinsatz in
Castrop-Rauxel in der Nacht zum 8 Januar
zwei Brüder aus Iran werden festgenommen
sie soll mit hochgiftigen Substanzen ein
islamistischen Terroranschlag geplant
haben Gift wird nicht gefunden bei einer
erneuten Durchsuchung vergangenen
Donnerstag wurden dann wohl Substanzen
gefunden es sind die bisherigen
durchsuchungsobjekte nochmals ohne
besondere Sicherungsvorkehrungen wie zum
Beispiel spezielle Schutzanzüge
durchgeführt worden hierbei konnten
weitere Beweismittel sichergestellt
werden deren Untersuchung dauert an im
Rechtsausschuss des
nordrhein-westfälischen Landtags wird
heute bekannt dass das Bundeskriminalamt
am 30 Dezember den Hinweis auf den
geplanten Anschlag bekam in der
Silvesternacht sollte eine größere
Menschenmenge angegriffen werden erst
eine Woche später griff die Polizei in
Nordrhein-Westfalen zu die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Düsseldorf hat
am 7 januar von dem Verdacht in denen es
hier geht erfahren und hat umgehend ein
Durchsuchungsbeschluss erwürgt und
diesen am selben Tag vollstreckt was
geschah mit den Informationen des
Bundeskriminalamts vom 30 Dezember diese
Frage bleibt offen ich verstehe nicht
warum weder das Innenministerium noch
das Justizministerium in
Nordrhein-Westfalen irgendwelche
Informationen erhalten hat ich muss
sagen da muss man schon tief durchatmen
die Ermittlungen im Fall Castrop-Rauxel
dauern an und die Debatte um die Frage
wie Behörden mit dem Terrorverdacht
umgegangen sind
seit Jahrzehnten war der Wohlstand in
der Welt nicht mehr so ungleich verteilt
wie aktuell das ist die bittere Bilanz
der Entwicklungsorganisation Oxfam zum
Auftakt des Weltwirtschaftsforums heute
Abend in Davos
ukrainekrieg und Energiekrise würden von
Lebensmittel und Energiekonzernen
genutzt besonders hohe Preise
durchzusetzen und das habe extrem reiche
noch reicher und extrem Arme noch
ärmer gemacht zu den Hintergründen
Christoph desterell
einer von 13 Millionen die in
Deutschland wissen wie sich Armut
anfühlt Alex aus Berlin 15 Jahre willst
studieren und ist mit Hartz IV groß
geworden heißt zum Beispiel für Essen
und Kleidung muss er beim Hilfswerk
Arche Nachfragen während seine
Mitschüler tragen und essen dürfen was
sie wollen er kann es nur gelassen
nehmen statt mich nicht wirklich
die haben deren Leben ich habe mein
Leben
Wohlstand und Besitz waren nie fair
verteilt aber gerade wird die
Ungerechtigkeit zunehmend dramatisch
überall wir sehen erstmal seit 25 Jahren
dass nicht nur der der extreme Reichtum
zunimmt sondern auch die extreme Armut
also das ist auf jeden Fall eine
Besonderheit in dieser Situation Google
man das Stichwort Milliarden Gewinne
zeigt sich nicht nur bei den
Energiekonzernen gehen die Bilanzen
gerade durch die Decke seit Beginn der
corona-pandemie hat das reichste Prozent
der Weltbevölkerung und 24 Billionen
Euro Gewinn gemacht das sind rund 67%
aller Gewinne die in dieser Zeit erzielt
wurden in Deutschland landeten beim
reichsten einen Prozent sogar 81% aller
Gewinne
warum vieles ist teurer geworden durch
den ukrainekrieg viele Konzerne haben
profitiert und dann sind da noch die
sehr niedrigen Zinsen
das sorgt immer dafür dass die
Aktienkurs nach oben explodieren und
natürlich Immobilienpreise auch und die
Reichen haben Aktien und Immobilien
gleichzeitig wird es für die Armen auf
der Welt immer enger
aktuell leiden 828 Millionen Menschen
Hunger jeder zehnte weltweit auch weil
im vergangenen Jahr Lebensmittel global
um 18% teurer wurden und die
Energiepreise sogar um
59%. besser geht es den Armen erst wenn
die Reichen abgeben glaubt Oxfam und
fordert deswegen dringend höhere Steuern
für Superreiche und Konzerne damit die
Welt nicht ganz aus dem Gleichgewicht
gerät
finalente kathurato Titeln italienische
Zeitungen endlich gefasst nach 30 Jahren
Suche ist es italienischen
Spezialkräften gelungen den
meistgesuchten Mafioso des Landes zu
verhaften Mateo Messina deno der soll
schlimmste Verbrechen in Auftrag gegeben
haben und galt als Chef der
sizilianischen Cosa Nostra über den
spektakulären Zugriff der in einer
Privatklinik in Palermo erfolgte
berichtet Andreas Postel
in den frühen Morgenstunden schlägt eine
Spezialeinheit der Carabinieri im
sizilianischen Palermo zu und verhaftet
den meistgesuchten Mafiaboss Italiens
Strategen der Massaker von 1992/93
festgenommen das war eine Schuld die die
Republik Italien gegenüber den Opfern
jener Jahre hatte und diese Schuld ist
mit dem heutigen Tag teilweise beglichen
das ist das wichtigste für uns
in dieser Privatklinik ließ sich der
60-Jährige unter falschem Namen wegen
einer Krebserkrankung behandeln als die
Beamten ihn stellen gesteht er seine
wahre Identität er ist es Matteo
messinao
ein sensationeller Schlag gegen die Kosa
nostra so bedeutsam dass Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin Georgia Meloni
sofort nach Palermo kommt bei der zeigt
sich einen entschlossenes Italien das in
diesem Kampf nicht aufgegeben hat weil
es stärker ist als die Mafia das ist
eine wichtige Botschaft für unsere
Glaubwürdigkeit und den Stolz unserer
Nation der jetzt gefasste Mafiaboss wird
mitverantwortlich gemacht für die
tödlichen Bombenanschläge auf die Mafia
Jäger Giovanni Falcone und Paolo
bosselino 1992 eine Zäsur damals für
Italien die Bekämpfung der Mafia wird
zur nationalen Aufgabe
30 Jahre später erwarten die Ermittler
mit Spannung ob Matteo Messina de naro
nach seiner Festnahme bereit ist zur
kooperieren
als tanzende Esmeralda in der Verfilmung
des Glöckners von Notre Dame wurde sie
berühmt Gina Lollobrigida die große
italienische Schauspielerin mit der
sinnlichen Ausstrahlung war eine der
Ikonen des Goldenen Zeitalters in
Hollywood sie stand mit Größen wie
anthony Quinn Humphrey Bogart oder Burt
lenkes der vor der Kamera heute ist sie
im Alter von 95 Jahren in Rom gestorben
Jürgen Kehl erinnert
bitte mehr Italien geht kaum ein roter
Ferrari am Steuer Gina Lollobrigida auch
im hohen Alter liebt sie noch den großen
Auftritt
internationale Aufmerksamkeit und
Sehnsüchte weckt die Römerin luigina
Lollobrigida wie sie eigentlich heißt in
den 50ern mit leicht verdaulichen
Liebesfilmen
wir sehen uns wieder wir beide
in ihrer Glanz zahlt sie mir
Titelblätter als jede andere Italienerin
es gibt nur eine Gina nationale rund um
den Globus verzückt ihre Erscheinung ein
Massenpublikum besonders in Deutschland
so etwas hat Bayern noch nie erlebt aus
Italien kam generalobrigida und die
Landeshauptstadt standkopf die sonst so
ruhigen Münchner wurden von ihrer
Begeisterung förmlich hin und
hergerissen
vielleicht vergabere ich genau das was
die Deutschen an den Italienern so
sympathisch finden
sie erobert Hollywood kassiert die
höchsten Gagen und gerät in die Mühlen
der Boulevardpresse
eine Sache hat mich immer sehr gestört
die vielen bohrenden Blicke die mich
andauernd verfolgt haben
in den 70ern verliert sich die
Aufmerksamkeit nach ihrer Filmkarriere
fotografiert sie und entdeckt eine alte
Leidenschaften neu die Bildhauerei über
ihre Herzensangelegenheiten sagt die
einmal geschiedene selbst da habe sie
weniger Glück gehabt als andere
und bei den meisten wird sie wohl so in
Erinnerung bleiben Gina nationale als
Esmeralda in der Glöckner von Notre Dame
[Musik]
hat man lange nicht mehr gesehen so
Frust im deutschen Tennis erster Tag
Australian Open time deutscher weiter
Christin Zitat ein mülltonnenstart in
Melbourne nicht von mir ein Zitat sechs
deutsche Profis hatten zu Beginn die
Chance in Runde zwei einzuziehen niemand
kam weiter auch nicht Jule Niemeyer die
gegen die polnische Weltranglisten
ersteigertech ihr Potenzial zwar
andeutete aber letztlich doch in zwei
Sätzen unter
Lagune Niemeyer waren nah dran an der
Überraschung gegenüber schwer und weg
war es ein enges Match auf hohem Niveau
es ist einfach schwierig gegen die
Topspielerin wenn man da irgendwie bei
ein zwei Punkten nicht nicht da ist oder
sie einfach dann besser spielt trotz
großer Gegenwehr von Niemeyer gewann die
Polen Satz 1 mit 6:4 zu Beginn des
zweiten Satz des gelang der 23-Jährigen
deutschen aber ein Break sie führte
zwischenzeitlich sogar mit fünf zu drei
unterkämpfte sich in den Satz zurück und
hatte Matchball die Polen gewann seit
zwei mit sieben zu fünf und besiegelte
das knapp erst runden aus für Jule
Niemeyer in Melbourne
ARD und ZDF werden weiterhin ausführlich
von olympischen Sommer und Winterspielen
Berichten im Fernsehen sowie online
beide öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender
erhielten die Olympia Übertragungsrechte
von 2026 bis 2032
große Freude bei den Deutschen
Handballern durch den Erfolg gegen
Serbien vorzeitig die Hauptrunde
gesichert zu haben am Tag danach stand
vor allem Ruhe auf dem Programm
abschalten und Kräfte sammeln für die
nächsten Aufgaben sie lassen es locker
angehen Fußball statt Handballtraining
nach dem Sieg gegen Serbien die
Offensivleistung gestern in weiten
Teilen hervorragend abgesehen von einer
siebenminütigen Durststrecke ohne
eigenen Tor Erfolg diese Phase wird zu
seiner Sternstunde
bleibt Deutschland in Führung
Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten gibt es
dennoch ja wir wollen vor allem im
nächsten Schritt machen in der
Defensivleistung da haben wir noch ein
paar Entwicklungspotenziale die wir
heben wollen wenn man das siegreich
gestalten das Spiel dann gehen wir mit
einem sehr guten Gefühl in die
Hauptgründe
Katara gegen Algerien steht Deutschland
schon als Gruppensieger fest ausruhen
will sich das DHB-Team im letzten
Vorrundenspiel darauf aber nicht
ja morgen also gegen Algerien im ZDF zu
sehen 20 vor 6 Uhr geht's los Dankeschön
Christin ob es beim Wetter so
ungemütlich weitergeht das erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja horneffer
der Lambrecht Rücktritt auch noch mal
großes Thema bei Marietta Slomka im
heute journal ab 21:45 Uhr das 19 Uhr
heute Team bedankt sich fürs Interesse
wünscht noch einen entspannten Abend
tschüss und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend sehr schön können Sie hier
die tiefdruckspirale Gero erkennen Gero
ist heute vom Ärmelkanal weiter ostwärts
gezogen und hat zumindest vorübergehend
kräftige Schneefälle mitgebracht zum
Beispiel in der Eifel im Hunsrück im
Taunus oder auch im Westerwald Schnee
und Schneeregen werden jetzt noch in der
Nacht weiter Richtung Nordosten ziehen
machen Sie sich also bitte auf rutschige
Straßen gefasst denn die Temperaturen
sinken auf plus 4 bis -2 Grad und über
dem Neuschnee am Alpenrand geht sogar
bis -8 Grad runter die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 0
Grad in den Mittelgebirgen unterm
Alpenrand und sechs Grad in der Lausitz
oder auch am Oberrhein morgen Vormittag
geht's noch einige Schnee Regenschauer
hier nordöstlich der Elbe und an der
Nordsee reicht's auch mal für einen
Wintergewitter sonst wird das ein
freundlicher Dienstag zwischen all den
Wolken zeigt sich auch mal die Sonne im
Südwesten kommen neue Wolken heran die
bringen Schneeregen und Schnee vom
Schwarzwald bis ins Allgäu aktuell liegt
ja wirklich nicht viel Schnee vielleicht
in der Rhön mal so 10 cm auf der
Zugspitze 1, 50 das allerdings wird sich
dann bis morgen Abend ein bisschen
ändern sie sehen wie sich die
Schneefälle etwas ausweiten und damit
wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt einen schönen
Abend